et comme tous les lundis soirs c'est le
7-8 sport avec anthony rech bonsoir
bonsoir on va parler football et course
à pied
oui nous parlerons du projet humanitaire
de lucie bididi bénéteau vous êtes avec
nous bonsoir à vous vous êtes la récente
championne de france vétérans du 800 m
en salle titre obtenu il ya quelques
semaines et vous courir cette saison
pour une association qui s'appelle pour
un sourire d'enfant
mais tout d'abord nous allons nous
allons parler football place au football
parce que ça fait un petit moment qu'on
a pas eu de foot dans le 7-8 sport et
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau etienne
rideau vous êtes l'entraîneur des
seniors ii lui est venue en cours
bonsoir à vous asseoir
alors on vous invitez puisque bas cette
saison donc comme depuis plusieurs
saisons les seigneurs de lui en cours
sont en promotion d'honneur et le
parcours à mi saison est d'ailleurs très
bon puisque enfin même un peu plus que
mi saison puisque vous êtes encore dans
dans le bon wagon vous avez été en tête
pendant pendant un petit moment
d'ailleurs je vous propose donc de jeter
un petit coup d'oeil au classement
on va voir ça tout de suite voilà vous
avez 35 points vous êtes à égalité de
points avec linas montlhéry et
saint-maur-des-fossés vous étiez en tête
mais il ya eu quelques petites
déconvenues récemment sur ce sur ce
premier tableau laquelle est votre votre
sativa votre sentiment
on a notre juste place je pense donc on
est on est satisfait d'être là de
pouvoir encore jouer là la course à la
montée
c'était l'objectif au début de saison
c'est cette course à la montée pour une
éventuelle dhr n'en est pas réellement
d'objectifs par rapport à sam on m'a
simplement de demander d'essayer de
finir dans les cinq premiers ce que
derrière ça il y avait éventuellement
une refonte de championnat donc c'est à
dire que les six derniers s'étaient
devait descendre
si ça se faisait donc on sait pas encore
comment ça va évoluer au niveau de la
fédé maintenant on mérite cette place là
même si actuellement c'est un peu
difficile donc on est on est satisfait
d'être là oui actuellement c'est un peu
plus difficile vous disiez parce que en
2013 bas pour l'instant au niveau au
niveau des victoires cc 00 13 apporte sa
science alors non pas un très bon
chiffre par an pour certains à sa porte
pour nous wen ont effectivement on est
on est mars ses deuxièmes parties
passait super bien donc on essaie de
faire de faire au mieux on a beaucoup de
beaucoup de paramètres qui font qu'on
est en difficulté actuellement
ces revers consécutifs ça met une
ambiance un peu difficile au sein du
groupe les joueurs arrivent à rester
bien concerné est soudé c'est à dire
quand on a l'habitude de gagner ce
combat on avait réussi à faire une série
de résultats très positifs notamment
quatre victoires d'affilée on n'est pas
avoir apprécié la victoire la défaite
quand on fait de la compet
on met de côté on essaie de la met de
côté donc le groupe actuellement
effectivement commencé un petit peu
appartient un peu dans tous les sens on
essaie de serre et ça c'est pas évident
en plus vous êtes sur le banc de l'usb
en cours depuis cette saison vous êtes
arrivé à l'intersaison vous prenez un
groupe un peu en cours comme ça se passe
ça doit pas être évident justement à
gérer ce genre de situation quand on
connaît pas trop les joueurs non non la
préparation d'avant-saison enjoint fait
que j'ai pu faire un tour de l'effectif
de cerner les points forts les points
faibles je me suis aussi basé sur le
travail de mon prédécesseur christian et
fait un très bon travail ceci dit et
donc non non c'est être c'est le job on
s'habitue facile qu'à trop cher comment
vous expliquer un peu ses bases ce coup
de pompe entre guillemets ce clip calgon
que vous avez là depuis 2013 c'est un
manque d'effectif une infirmerie qui ai
un peu plein parce que je sais que vous
avez des blessés aussi masse et les deux
c'est l'ensemble des deux effectives en
est parti sur un choix sportif du club
de prendre de très peu de seniors pour
pouvoir intégrer les jeunes du club
donc ça partait d'une très bonne
intention mais quand l'effectif est trop
juste et puis on a vraiment une
hécatombe de blessures avec huit à neuf
blessés
sur un groupe de dix-huit ça fait voilà
c'est c'est compliqué c'est très
compliqué et pourtant les jeunes sont
plutôt bons cette année parce qu'on les
a suivis notamment il ya quelques
semaines leur épopée en gambardella
mais là encore une marche entre les u19
et est cette poule de promotion
d'honneur
voilà tout à fait bon déjà c'est un très
bon groupe c'est vrai avec beaucoup de
qualités mais un groupe qui a pas vécu
de grands matchs ou deux heureux de
championnat difficile au niveau ligue
en jeunes intégrés des seniors c'est un
monde différent il ya des différences
d'âge qui vont jusqu'à 20 ans il ya déjà
trente huit ans quand on aligne un genre
de 18 ans qui clame ans d'expérience
c'est compliqué pour lui et je pense
aussi que le parcours en gambardella des
jeunes u19 à leur a fait un petit peu de
mal mentalement mentalement ça leur a
pris beaucoup d'énergie revenir dans un
circuit un petit peu traditionnelle de
championnat la routine c'est pas
toujours évident pourquoi après avoir
joué la g auxerre on rappellera la super
duke ou comment les motive alors à bâle
en 2013 mais il faut des victoires et
les ja à la motivation à devenir déjà
deux ans et si on fait la compet et puis
si l'intérêt le groupe première c'est
une ambition personnelle
s'ils n'en sont pas capables voilà et ça
prouve leur limite aussi donc après nous
on est là peau merci de vous regarder à
côté
ouais non non faut pas les mettre dans
un confort totalement absolue tout le
temps faux faux faux les râleurs le chou
qui se remettre en question ce je pense
qu'ils sont arrivés à un moment où on
pensait qu'il y avait des acquis et les
acquiesce stage la foufoune bah voilà
oui j'y serais allé jouer moins six à
moins de jesper sa valeur apportée dans
le futur surtout quoi et alors avec
c'est donc ce manque cruel de victoires
en 2013 vous sentez un petit peu en
danger justement par rapport à cette
baisse dans classement ou pas du tout
pour l'instant vous êtes serein
moi je suis serein je moi je suis avec
ce que j'ai je pense avoir tiré le
meilleur possible de ce groupe là pour
le moment il ya déjà des soucis
d'effectif de blessure
peut pas faire grand chose donc on là je
sais de palier à ça mais je suis très
heureux non moi je fais je fais de la
compet je fais ça depuis longtemps et je
sais c'est un mauvais moment à passer on
va récupérer des blessés on va
s'accrocher on est pas même si les
victoires sont sont criantes au niveau
du score on n'est pas trop loin non plus
qua non dans le jeu même si on fait pas
des supers matches on est c'est le
résultat sont un peu flatteur pour les
adversaires mais je suis pas voilà faut
passer à autre chose après une dernière
question vous venez d'arriver sur le sur
le banc de guyancourt vous avez envie de
vous inscrire dans la durée avec avec ce
club
oui j'aimerais bien à prades à certaines
conditions
à mon arrivée s'est fait un peu
précipitamment on n'a pas eu le temps de
poser certaines choses donc j'ai accepté
un
ces voix là quoi c'est à avoir un vin
pour un projet sportif cohérent se
donner les moyens de le faire donc je
financiers humains financiers donc
souvent là où le bât blesse un oui ou un
autre niveau ça ça peut jouer un peu
mais pas papa c'est pas une des
priorités mais c'est sûr que ça peut
jouer un petit peu après c'est surtout
sur le plan humain et la qualité du
groupe pourra après il faut se donner
les moyens de réussir votre prochain
match c'est on va aubervilliers réserve
de cfa ça va être compliqué
effectivement pas très bien on suivra
tout ça et je crois que prochain oui oui
tout à fait oui ça va ça marche et
parlait d'ailleurs ça peut en parler sur
ce prochain samedi puisque quand on a
préparé l'émission évidemment je vous
parlais de ce football féminin qui
brille sur sur la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et il ya une
équipe qui cartonne ce sont les
féminines d'elancourt notamment l'équipe
a été créé il ya quatre ans et depuis
elles ne font que gagner quasiment elles
sont invaincues cette saison et
tyrannise alors pour laver
il a brillé c'est dommage que vous ne
soyez pas entraîneur de foot féminin la
vérité je crois est donc cette année le
tyrannise totalement leur poule de
promotion de ligue 1 sujet réalisé avec
guillaume campent depuis quatre ans elle
écrase tout ou presque sur leur passage
lors de leur première saison les
féminines d'elancourt terminent
troisièmes de leur championnat à 7
la seconde est stratosphérique 130 buts
marqués pour un seul encaissé
une réussite menée sous l'impulsion de
leur entraîneur dany l'aigle devenu le
sorcier il football féminin de l'eau etc
non c'est pas magique c'est que je pense
qu'on a réussi a réussi à créer un lien
entre les joueuses moi même et les
personnes le staff
et puis les éducateurs qui qui sont là
toutes les semaines pour pour les filles
et on a réussi à créer
on va dire un groupe une famille quoi
voilà je pense qu'on tire tous dans le
même sens quand il ya des choses à 10
janvier les choses on évite de passer
par un point b la saison dernière les
amazones évolué pour la première fois
dans un championnat à onze et rate la
montée pour deux petits ponts avec cette
réussite l'effectif atteint aujourd'hui
40 joueuses mais les élans courtoise
doivent encore grandir comme en témoigne
leur défaite en coupe de france 9 buts à
0 face à saint maur club de division
d'honneur
évoluant quatre divisions au dessus de
l'eau et c'est ce qui va nous poser
souci ça va être
d'être confronté à un niveau et à
meilleur que nous parce que actuellement
toutes les équipes qu'on a rencontrés
qui était meilleur que nous bah on est
et on était complètement déstructuré on
n'arrivait pas à jouer donc on sait
gagner mais pour l'instant c'est pas on
sait pas perdre elancourt réussi là où
de nombreux club yvelinois se sont cassé
les dents
avoir un projet viable sur la durée lors
de cette 11e journée les filles de dany
l'aigle continuent leur sans faute cette
saison en s'imposant face à colon 3 buts
à 0
avec dix points d'avancé sur leurs
dauphines et amazon ont désormais la
montée en promotion d'honneur au bout de
leurs crampons
ça donne envie
une équipe comme ça etienne de la
coacher non c'est toujours intéressant
c'est sûr dans le football féminin c'est
se développe bien il faut que ça
continue comme ça je pense que c'est
important
je parle beaucoup de montigny à papeete
un nom mais maintenant il ya les
amazones d'elancourt tout à fait on va
rester dans le sport féminin si vous
voulez bien catherine avec lucie
dibenedetto vous êtes licencié à le à
saint quentin et vous êtes la nouvelle
championne de france vétérans du 800
mètres bonsoir à vous ça fait bon soir
alors anthony vous venez ce soir
évidemment pour vos performances mais
aussi parce que vous avez un projet qui
vous tient à coeur
cette saison c'est que vous courrez pour
récolter des dons pour l'association
pour un sourire d'enfant qui est une
association qui vient en aide aux
enfants du cambodge
tout à fait oui tout à fait cette année
je me suis lancé dans une difficile otiv
à une association humanitaire
et donc quand j'ai eu l'opportunité des
faits ça je me suis dit bah c'est
excellent je précise je vais être
australienne lui si tout avait l'air
d'un très joli accent mais tout à fait
j'essaie le lointain qu'on est ravi
d'accueillir tout
dominés terrienne oui le tibet voilà et
comment ça vous est venue alors ce
projet à quel moment vous êtes dire je
vais je vais essayer de récolter des
noms en grâce à mes performances
donc en fait c'est un hymne à mika lancé
un défi spots yves lalanne est déniée et
quand j'ai su ça quand j'ai vu ce projet
j'étais extrêmement touchée et je me
suis dit c'est quelque chose que me que
me parle quelque chose que que j'ai
l'habitude de en vedette de fait aux
étangs commencé lienne on fait beaucoup
sélection il ya beaucoup de malades
opérations comme ça on associe le sport
ou d'autres activités à des récoltes
caritative est exactement et il faut
savoir que le sport peut être on peut on
va dire
égoïste on fait ça bien ce que
nous-mêmes de notre performance nous
fait plaisir
et quand on peut associer le sport avec
une session humanité peu idée
effectivement des enfants au cambodge
qui sont vraiment en détresse voilà je
pense qu'on a tous on a tous gagné on a
gagné peut-être pas trois fois en
pratique la passion on fait des chronos
et en plus on aide une association comme
comme l'association point sur les
enfants est alors votre système de dons
est un peu particulier et que c'est à
dire je vous donne 20 euros aujourd'hui
comment ça se passe derrière
voilà donc en fait tu peux me motive et
moi même je me lançais un petit jeu donc
et je demande à mes amis à mon réseau
quand ils font une demande de départ et
il faut savoir que c'est donc peut être
multiplié par 2 3 ou 4 à fonction de mes
résultats aux champions de france
abordent plus ajoute à son meilleur plus
la somme et multipliez vos là tout à
fait donc en fait les décès que si j'ai
fait un podium
votre don de départ que ces 20 euros
sera multiplié par deux si j'ai fait
deux podiums au sénat médaille d'or
votre nom ne dit pas cela me supplier
patois et si je fais au moins deux
médailles d argent vaut ce n'était pas
simple calcul complexe comprend que plus
jamais ne plus vous engrangez deux
victoires plus forcément il ya de la wii
tout à fait moi je me suis dit il faut
que je cherchais quelque chose qui me
rendent motivé pour mon côté bien ce
donc le côté gauche côté j'avais déjà un
multiplier les dons puisque vous êtes
vous avez gagné ce titre de championne
de france 2 était en vol a donc le défi
cessé en deux fois donc la premier fois
c'est en salle donc les 800 mhz et en
salle que c'était le livre il est tout à
fait où j'ai gagné donc ça c'était un
grand moment pour moi et pepy est ce
donc là mais dans son sens dijon motogp
et patois et dites-nous en tout alors on
sait combien je connais donc en totale à
aujourd'hui je suis à neuf mille neuf
mille euros que c'est que c'est vraiment
super vous attendiez à voir autant de
dons comme ça une telle générosité des
gens qui vous entourent plus de façon
plus ou moins proche
non pas du tout si j'étais vraiment en
fait je me suis lancé et plonger
vraiment dans l'inconnu et je ne savais
pas comment ça va se passer
j'ai causés mais doit que ça se passe
pour le mieux et est que ces machins
parce que le petit côté stress et si ça
ne marche pas qu'est ce que je vais
faire donc
et alors c'est dont je crois qu'il vous
servent aussi à aller vers un projet
assez précises c'est pour pour une
cantine je crois au cambodge voilà tout
à fait donc le projet les dons vont
sévir peut constituer une nouvelle
l'espace cantine en fait c'est un prix à
un prix audi cantine qui fait à peu près
160 m² et le budget pour cette cantine
c'est 39 millions euros je suis pas là
encore mais j'avertis déjà mais c'est
déjà un bon début en a fait donc je me
suis dit c'est à mon échelle
nous ça reste un projet peut-être que je
peux atteindre est alors au delà de la
motivation que vous expliquer tout à
l'heure le fait de courir pour ses
enfants
ça vous apporte quelque chose
personnellement ça vous c'est une
expérience enrichissante pour vous bah
oui tout à fait j'ai trouvé que la
motivation c'était
j'étais jamais motivé comme ça j'essaie
de me donner à de me donner à fond de
fait les choses au maximum et dit
vraiment à penser à cet enfant quand ben
soi et de penser à tout le monde
mon club d'athlé 50 ans mais amy pièce
aux gentils vous qui vous soutiennent la
toux le tout le monde que mes soutiens
et en plus l'association payer ce qu'ils
ont vraiment d'espoir donc je pense que
oui la motivation est en plus le fait
quand on est des gens on est des gens je
vous demande ça parce que quand je suis
venu vous voir à l'entraînement la
semaine dernière
vous croyez un petit peu trop vite par
rapport à votre temps de passage a
beaucoup beaucoup de motivation au delà
la motivation il ya vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de d'enthousiasmant il si vous
voulez vous un précieux et alors au
niveau des prochaines compétitions est
ce que vous avez des chances voilà des
objectifs pour encore augmenter ce
capital financier ben en tout cas oui
voila je vais pas m'arrêter là je vais
continuer à a contacté mon réseau
j'espère que aussi sept passages ce soit
sur votre plateau connais mon projet est
aussi connaît l'association pour un
sourire d'enfant que le siège est à
versailles
donc et alors vous allez courir pour aux
championnats d'europe c'est sa voix la
dent en plein air cette fois ci un nom
je réponds ça les championnats de france
en plein air en voilà tout à fait donc
pu rester bien ce monsieur toujours le
contact de la compétition le push en
étape c'est de courir les championnats
d'europe en salle qui se passe en
espagne le mois de mars le 20 mars très
bien on suivra tout ça lucie plaisir
mais en espérant que vous récoltiez
encore un peu plus d'argent d'ici la fin
de la saison merci beaucoup d'être venu
ce soir sur le plateau de tv films et
s'ils avouent on enchaîne catherine
willows effet après midi vous me disiez
vous cherchez une activité physique est
oui oui le soir est d'abord et
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est brutal
et je sais où vous allez pouvoir aller
vous dépensez après le 7 8 pour ce soir
8 août a fait à l'aéroboxe ça vous dit
quelque chose non non aéroboxe donc pas
du tout c'est un cours de remise en
forme plutôt surprenant de quoi vous
défouler mesdames
après une journée de travail l'image de
guillaume campe ce mélange de fitness et
d'arts martiaux comme le kick boxing le
taekwondo l'aéroboxe est un cocktail des
tonneaux et lorsque l'on n'est pas
habitué des coups de poing sont très
vite moins énergique
c'est le seul sport de l'année sur un
balcon
c'est un petit peu intensif mais celle
là c'est surtout le menu parfait pour
oublier le stress du travail par
batterie de coups de pieds dans le vide
tout cas convivialité du coup elle
dynamisme des civils oui ça va bien on
tiendra le coup c'est un cours qui est
très ludique qui plaît énormément
justement au public femme parce qu'il ya
une dépense d'énergie
c'est pas très compliqué et voilà c'est
un défouloir après le travail qui plaît
beaucoup à l'origine l'aéroboxe était
une activité physique très pour la gente
féminine
mais en cherchant bien au fond de la
salle quelques curieux s'y essaye non
sans difficulté car tous ces bons points
7 je suis fumeur quant au cardio c'est
vraiment bon exceptionnellement ce corps
était gratuit mercredi dernier dans le
cadre de la semaine de la femme à magny
les hameaux
ce week-end voisins le bretonneux
accueil est une étape de la coupe des
yvelines de futsal les clubs saint
quentinois était évidemment de la partie
comme montigny venus se mesurer aux
spécialistes de la discipline images de
guillaume comme dix équipes yvelinoise
s'affrontaient ce week-end à voisins le
bretonneux dans le cadre de la coupe des
yvelines de futsal des moins de 17 ans
montini alignait une équipe composée
uniquement de joueurs de foot à 11
cette compétition fait donc office de
parenthèse dans la saison en plein air
qui rentrent très très vite dans le
match car foot à onze on a quand même 90
minutes et on arrive
même si on craque le premier quart
d'heure on sait que derrière il nous
reste un peu de temps pour aménager le
mac
on vient pour aussi satisfaire nos
joueurs les plus méritants parce que
c'est aussi une récompense
ça aussi ça peut passer par une
récompense parce que ils viennent deux
fois par semaine sans traîner son
tout le temps l'intensité beaucoup plus
présente dans le futsal qu'en plein air
venir se frotter aux spécialistes permet
donc de travailler d'autres aspects du
jeu comme la circulation rapide à une ou
deux touches de balle ça a été compliqué
on n'a pas très bien joué on s'est pas
super appliqué on n'a pas été percutant
dans les actions donc on a pris 5 0 mais
s'est passé pas vraiment mérité on a
essayé mais bon il me manquait la
rapidité dans les comptes éliminés dès
les matches de poule montini va pouvoir
se recentrer sur le championnat de foot
à 11 de leur côté voisins le bretonneux
et versailles se qualifie pour les demi
finales le 17 mars prochain à léon tony
comme tous les lundis on va passer aux
résultats sportifs du week-end
beaucoup de championnats connaissait une
courte pause ce week-end en football à
l'exception de la vie de division
d'honneur où évoluent versailles
les versaillais se sont inclinés
malheureusement sur la pelouse d ulysse
un but à zéro c'est leur troisième match
sans victoire mais ils conservent tout
de même leur place sur le podium de
division d'honneur chez les femmes
excellent week-end pour les club saint
quentinois en revanche 16e journée de
division 2 montigny s'impose à bischheim
5 buts à 3 un petit score de babyfoot
grâce à un triplé notamment de
l'inévitable margot robin lésigny
monteyne reste dans le ventre mou du
championnat à la 7e place en promotion
de ligue les féminines d'elancourt
continuent leur sans faute cette saison
elles se sont imposés facilement à
domicile 3 buts à 0 face à colombes dont
ce magnifique coup de pied reprise du
pied gauche pardon en pleine lucarne
alors on va le voir voilà que l'on voit
sur l'action près sur l'action suivante
voilà cela arrive à l'entrée de la
surface un peu lobé cette reprise du
pied gauche moins dominatrice que
d'habitude dans les filles de dany
l'aigle mais à cause peut-être d'une
ambiance assez électrique au bord et sur
le terrain les dvd saint-quentinoise
scelle le sort du match sur ce
débordement côté gauche pour s'imposer
finalement 3 buts à 0 au classement de
cette poule de promotion de ligue
les joueuses de dany l'aigle se baladent
littéralement avec 44 points 11 journées
un bilan parfait toujours invaincu cette
saison la belle aventure continue pour
les amazones
il ne leur manque plus qu'une victoire
pour être assuré de la montée en
promotion d'honneur et on va changer de
sport on va s'intéresser au rugby oui
lors de cette 16ème journée de fédérale
3 plaisir s'est imposé avec la manière
chez le relégable nogent le rotrou 26 à
7 4 essais inscrits et point de bonus
offensif en prime
le prc reste troisième au classement à
égalité de points avec poteaux combo
c'était d'ailleurs la semaine du rugby
catherine la semaine dernière dont dans
le département avec les journées des
ambassadeurs du rugby qui faisaient
étape à versailles
l'occasion pour les jeunes de côtoyer
des anciennes stars et les stars
actuelles du top 14 mais aussi
entraîneur et arbitre une journée
pendant laquelle le maître mot était
plaisir de jouer et respect 1 c'est
vraiment prendre du plaisir ce jeu c'est
le jeu de la chamaille c'est le jeu de
je pense de ce qui est profondément en
la nature humaine
donc c'est d'y être et puis après c'est
le petit voilà parce qu'ils sont comme
ça comme ils nous voient arriver ils
sont un peu plus aller coûte donc ça
aide les éducateurs à ce qu'ils se
concentrent sur des
comment des aspects de comportement et
d'attitude je crois que malgré les
enjeux qui a est le championnat qui est
de plus en plus élevées en termes de jeu
et un terme d'un enjeu je crois que le
respect existe toujours un valeur
habiterez je crois que c'est une valeur
sûre et les temps que ce respect
perdurera dans le futur je crois que ça
ça permettra à ce que les matchs se
déroulent aux rythmes dans un
environnement serein et sans débordement
je crois et du basket maintenant pour
continuer des bonnes nouvelles pour les
féminines de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles se sont repris ce
week-end à domicile en s'imposant face à
arras 70 53
les joueuses de vinko berdych met fin à
une série de quatre défaites
consécutives et reste leader de leur
poule de nationale 2 chez les hommes
cela va nettement mieux pour trappe un
le sct enchaîne avec une seconde
victoire consécutive et s'impose sur le
parquet dorment 88 à 81 au classement
avec sept victoires trappe sort enfin de
la zone rouge qu'ils fréquentaient
depuis trop longtemps cette saison avec
28 points devant le mans et maubeuge
ils conservent toutes leurs chances donc
de se sauver en nationale 2 et on va
changer de sport va parler de tennis de
table avec par contre la week end assez
contrastés pour le club saint quentinois
quatrième journée de nationale 2 les
féminines d'elancourt se déplacer chez
le solide quatrième de ses poules c'est
poitiers ce week end
mais malgré une belle résistance les
saint quentinois se sont inclinés de
justesse 10 matchs à huit
dans les autres matches de national 2 de
leur côté les féminines de l'entente
voisin saint-arnoult se sont imposés à
nîmes sur le même score mais dans le
sens inverse 10 matchs à huit cette fois
ci ils étaient à l'extérieur et ce grâce
à ce déplacement et cette victoire à
l'extérieur est bien au classement les
joueuses de geoffrey nisand assurent
leur maintien en nationale 2 on le voit
avec 10 points et l'encours est un peu
plus loin la cinquième place avec 7
points mais le maintien reste encore
tout à fait jouable pour les élans
courtoise et du coup grâce à cette
victoire et ben joué-lès-tours et
voisins saint-arnoult vont se disputer
jusqu'à la fin la montée tout simplement
nationale une et anthony ont fini avec
le paris nice
oui on peut pas on peut pas éviter un
l'édition 2013 par des 2 où il hier un
prologue de 2,9 km dans les rues de la
ville yvelinoise remporté par le
surprenant damien gaudin devant le
champion de france du contre-la-montre
sylvain chavanel pour une petite seconde
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sans le
sport ça
oui merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi ce 7,8
sport cette nouvelle édition
n'hésitez pas à commenter toute
l'émission sur les réseaux sociaux à
lundi prochain bonne soirée